Now let's implement
the startOver method.
How should we implement this method?
Which class should be responsible for
navigating back to the root of the app?
In this case, the answer is
the UINavigationController class.
Each ViewController has
a navigation controller property.
It's an optional that references
the navigation controller that a given
ViewController is embedded in.
When a ViewController receives
the indication to start over,
it can communicate with
the navigation controller.
And here you can see the careful
unwrapping of the optional.
We could just pop off the current
view controller like this, but
we want to go all the way
back to the beginning.
So we call popToRootView controller.
Here's a recap of the two
properties we just learned about.
The navigation item property
specifies features of the nav bar.
The navigationController property
provides a reference back to
the navigation controller for
programmatic control of
view controller popping.
Now take some time to get to
know these properties and
get that start-over button working for
all the endpoints in your story.